[Music]
hello there you're watching the press
preview our first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive so it's time
to see what's making the headlines with
the political editors of the daily
mirror and the sun pepper creera and
harry cole so very good evening to both
of you really good to see you both um
i'm pleased to say that both pippa and
harry will be here with us until just
before midnight
so let's take a look then what's making
tomorrow's front pages and the eye
carries the stark headline putin bombs
civilians showing the skyline of kiev
ablaze
the financial times pictures a destroyed
ukrainian tank on the streets of kharkiv
after russian forces launched a heavy
assault on the city
the guardian reports russia's assaults
on ukrainian cities defies western
sanctions and peace talks
barbaric the times headlines with the
prime minister's comment about russian
strikes on ukraine
the sun leads with a photo of a
ten-year-old girl who was shot dead with
her parents by russian soldiers her name
was paulina
meanwhile the metro quotes a doctor who
tried unsuccessfully to save the life of
a six-year-old child who was hit by a
russian shell he told the camera crew
show this to putin
the outrage at that little girl's death
is also the main story for the telegraph
fight for the innocence the plight of
children during this conflict also
features on the front of the mirror
that same photo is on the express but
with the headline monstrous
the daily mail contrasts with the
humanity of its readers who've raised
over a million pounds for the ukrainian
people with what it insists is vladimir
putin's inhumanity
and in a moment of rare levity the star
shows a ukrainian farmer attempting to
tow a russian tank off his land
with his tractor
and just a reminder by scanning the qr
code that you'll see on screen during
the program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's papers for yourself
while you watch us
and so let's bring in a pipa clearer and
harry cole to go through some of those
front pages and pippa day five of
russia's invasion and as you would
expect once again all the front pages
dominated with some bleak headlines
about the war there you've picked out
the eye first of all uh with the
headline putin bombs civilians and and
it's that
that statement but also that mood that
kind of dominates the front pages
tomorrow doesn't it
yes many of them feature either as the
eye does buildings which have been
destroyed by attacks by the russians or
indeed images very sort of moving
emotive images of children that have
lost their lives as a result of it and
of course what you need to remember is
that we're pushing the end of the fifth
day of this conflict and
and vladimir putin is not going the way
that he expected to everything that
western intelligence agencies and
western leaders tell us is that um he
expected to be able to storm in meet
very little resistance from ukrainian
forces let alone ukrainian people
and for president zielinski and his
entourage to flee the country and to
very quickly be able to install a puppet
regime and then withdraw but but keep
ukraine in its orbit in russia's orbit
um sort of you know trying to recreate
the soviet union if you like and that
hasn't happened um he has met fierce
resistance from the ukrainian military
backed up by um
with weapons and support from western
allies
and he's met fierce resistance from
people and his tactics as a result have
changed he's got increasingly frustrated
he's faced with anger on the streets at
home in moscow and in and in and across
russia
and that's only likely to intensify as
the west steps up to the sanction regime
and he is
really i think probably in a position
now where he's desperate to get results
soon and therefore um what we're seeing
what we've seen today is an escalation
of the sort of tactics that he's
prepared to use focusing on civilians
focusing on civil targets
um and potentially committing war crimes
in some of those instances and the the i
like like i say is it sort of
encapsulated at all with with its um
with its summary on the front of of what
um
what has happened today
uh two obviously kiev is being circled
in the second biggest city kharkiv um is
has been targeted putin stepped up
russians have stepped up the bombing
campaign there heavy civilian losses
and uh very sadly we're likely to see
more of it in the days to come well
that's right harry and moving on to the
financial times they actually
concentrate on kharkiv the second
biggest city in ukraine russian rockets
pound kharkiv and day five
and not a single city has been taken so
far by russia in ukraine and as pippa
was hinting there this suggestion that
the tactics are changing and that the
weapons being used are ones that are
more indiscriminate and casualties uh
therefore rising sharply
yeah quite chilling briefing we have
tonight actually uh from what we will uh
enigmatically describe as western
officials um who say that some of the
images of the of the the weaponry that
puget is bringing up from his um from
the border up the supply lines uh just
the sheer force and scale of it means
that it has to be just by the laws of
physics more discriminatory in its um in
its horrible power but the problem is is
that he is clearly as pivo said um well
behind target um
taking a hell of a pounding today almost
suspiciously like indiscriminate weapons
aimed at civilians which is a war crime
which perhaps does show that frustration
but there's just an element of poor
planning going on in the fact that his
bridging equipment is stuck at the back
of the lines the you know some parts of
his uh of his uh assault are moving too
quickly to be refueled and despite this
buildup that's been going on from
november this does feel awfully rushed
and there was a really interesting stuff
raging around tonight about the the
fears that the the west's have in the
fact that perhaps putin is not taking
advice he might in fact be running a lot
of these military decisions himself
overruling um people that would know
better and the circle around him in the
kremlin is as small as uh as many in in
western intelligence circles could ever
remember it you know even in the heights
of the cold war they had the pollock
bureau they had the generals they had
the staff there these were at times
collective decisions um so there's a
real worry that actually the
we're dealing with an entirely
unpredictable enemy who is um perhaps
not making the most rash decisions and
that's when it becomes really scary i
think there's sort of 24 48 hours um for
him to sort of sort out the slightly
botched start to the attack um before i
really hope we don't start seeing him
lose his temper well yes and let's move
on to the metro shall we um pippa
because here is a headline that's
actually repeated on a couple of the
papers show this to putin and these are
a doctor's words aren't they um after he
failed to
to to help a little girl who was hit by
a shell
yeah there's a very striking image which
is on the front page of several um
papers of um
the girl being treated by doctors you
can just see in the background there the
paramedic with the the red outfit on
little girl lying on
an ambulance trolley and her mother in
the foreground with blood splattered on
her hat looking absolutely distraught as
the doctor struggled to save her life
and there was a video it was video shoot
footage which showed um a doctor who'd
been who've been aiming to save the life
of this six-year-old um
turning to the camera and angrily saying
to putin when
they realized the medics that this was
not going to be successful and the
little girl had lost her life show this
to putin the the the anger and the the
heartbreak of the medics that we're
trying so hard um save an innocent and
the ukrainians have announced today this
usually the sun there is another child's
ten-year-old polina features on the
front of a couple of of papers i mean
she looks like
many ten-year-olds i know you know
cheery smile and that sort of that pink
hair trying out the latest hairstyle
um the ukrainians have said that 16
children were killed um in ukraine in
the first four days that will even never
have inevitably risen
in the last 24 hours as the attacks have
become more focused on civilian areas on
blocks of flats on cars there's a
terrible
reportage about
a car which was attacked which had three
children in it who were effectively
incinerated alive
these are sort of standout awful tragic
moments in this conflict so far but as
the days go on we will inevitably hear
and see more of them and i think that's
what's most striking
to
people watching what's unfolding in
ukraine from abroad
the fact that
we hear stories of men
being asked to stay in ukraine to fight
men who have no military experience and
sending their daughters and their wives
and their girlfriends and their mothers
overseas to safety or at least to other
parts of the country that aren't sort of
right in the firing line
and these men feel it's their duty and
responsibility to to to protect them and
to protect their country but you know
frankly god knows what they're walking
into
in the coming days and um you know
it's it's we're very early on in this
conflict really and
all the suggestions from western
officials from
western intelligence and from our
government and others is that this is
likely to be project protracted lengthy
fight that the ukrainians are not going
to give up their country the russians
are determined not to lose face and the
results potentially are going to be
horrific and i just want to show the
front page of the daily telegraph next
because again show this to putin is
their
headline as well and in the copy it does
talk about russia being accused of war
crimes it quotes the chief prosecutor of
the international criminal court saying
he would soon begin a war crimes
investigation into the russian invasion
but harry i want to move on to the
guardian if that's okay and their main
headline says russia's deadly raids defy
sanctions and peace talks so let's talk
a little bit about both of those
elements peace talks first of all while
these
raids were going on there were also
peace talks underway in belarus
they didn't come up with any conclusions
we understand that there will be talks
again in the next few days but should we
be encouraged at all that there is some
diplomacy happening
yes of course they're always you know
it's better to keep those lines of
communication open but the absurdity of
the russian demands um of a
demilitarization of the ukraine and
permanent neutrality and a permanent uh
signing up not joined to nato that you
know they are they're going through the
motions but these are not serious uh
these are not serious talks i don't
think they will become serious talks
until um the the man and the kremlin
starts to feel the heat now we had the
first day of that today the i think one
of the most striking images wasn't you
know gazillionaire yachts being sort of
sun core or people trying to shift their
assets out of out of out of moscow you
know on in in bank accounts from
switzerland and various things like that
i thought a really striking image of
people queuing up at the at the
underground station in in in moscow and
their apple pay and their google play
and their smartphone apple wallets or
whatever whatever it is they use on the
metro isn't working because of those
restrictions and that's i think where
it's gonna be really interesting when if
you can turn the public against putin
not forget the oligarch class turn the
public against him i think it could be
um it could move quite quickly